après le désamiantage place à la
déconstruction à maurepas les
pelleteuses sont maintenant à l'oeuvre
pour faire disparaître toute trace du
centre aquatique fermé depuis 2015 pour
raisons de sécurité
vous pouvez réhabiliter c'était possible
mais ça a coûté beaucoup plus cher et
c'était j'allais dire est responsable
vis-à-vis des finances publiques puisque
de toute façon on est on aurait été
obligé à chaque fois de d'entretenir de
refaire des travaux puisque vous le
voyez la structure elle est complètement
corrodé les bassins n'était plus aux
normes depuis 1981 et datant des années
70 l'équipement accueillait particuliers
associations et scolaires la tante avant
de retrouver les bassins devrait prendre
fin en 2021 alors l'avenir de ce lieu
c'est un centre aquatique qui
correspondent aux besoins des habitants
moderne beaucoup plus ludique et
familial que ce qu'on a connu auparavant
on doit avoir un projet qui dure dans le
temps pour 30 ou 40 ans avec des
matériaux qui soit durable également
puisqu'on part certainement gardé des
bassins en inox qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les basses en carrelage que nous
avons connue et qui causait pas mal de
fuite pour la déconstruction qui va se
prolonger pendant l'été 157 mille euros
était investi un coût partagé avec la
ville d'elancourt elancourt qui
financera aussi la construction de la
prochaine structure tout comme la région
ile de france ou encore le département
montant global 15 millions d'euros
prochaine étape donc le choix dans un
concessionnaire privé en délégation de
service public ce dernier aura un an
pour réaliser la nouvelle piscine
à noter que 80 % des déchets de ce
chantier actuel seront recyclés annonce
le maire